arrêtons larnack de l'électricité c'est
sous ce slogan que les barcelonais ont
manifesté hier pour protester contre
l'augmentation du prix de l'énergie une
mobilisation à l'appel d'une quarantaine
d'organisations et de collectifs les
précisions avec notre reporter sur place
à clémentine l'europe
ici les montants des factures d'énergie
inquiète depuis plusieurs mois le prix
du mégawattheure a augmenté de 44 %
cette année et bat désormais des records
début octobre il a atteint le chiffre
impressionnant de 288 euros et 52,3
sentiers c'est un tarif jamais vu en
espagne alors en conséquence certaines
industries ont décidé de suspendre leur
production et l'inflation monte à plus
de 5% pendant la vie des espagnols le
plus cher et c'est un problème qui
inquiète d'autant plus ici en espagne
que l'hiver approche et c'est
traditionnellement une période où la
consommation d'énergie augmentent alors
ici pour les particuliers c'en est trop
à barcelone une quarantaine
d'organisations et collectifs ont décidé
de convoquer une manifestation pour
protester contre ce qu'ils considèrent
comme un abus je vous propose d'écouter
leurs revendications
on verra si on arrive à faire en sorte
qu'ils nous baisse le prix de
l'électricité ou au moins qu'il reste
comme il est et mais surtout que ça
arrête d'augmenter ils nous ont dit cet
été que ça allait continuer d'augmenter
et ça se confirme
le gouvernement espagnol pourrait créer
une entreprise publique comme il y en a
dans de nombreux pays qui produisait
distribuer de l'énergie le gouvernement
peut agir contre le monopole des trois
entreprises qui détiennent plus de 80%
du service de vente et de distribution
de l'énergie
nous sommes venus annoncer que la
question de l'électricité est
étroitement lié aux prix des loyers à
l'augmentation des prix de produits de
première nécessité et surtout liées au
coût de la vie qui nous fait traverser
une période très difficile en espagne
nous sommes venus apporter ce point de
vue qui n'est pas évident pour tous
alors face au problème du prix de
l'électricité ici en espagne le premier
ministre pedro sanchez a annoncé des
aides et il a baissé les ces impôts sur
la facture d'énergie il a également
promis un chèque de 90 euros pour que
les foyers les plus précaires puisse se
chauffer cet hiver